fly and no tail have been playing MOBAs
together for almost a decade they've
played on the same teams for most of
their lives in the same games in the
same roles they've grown together one
together and even lost together but
they've done something few other players
have together they've built one of the
most stable orgs in DotA history with
four major wins to their name and it all
started because the two men who led aji
found a brotherhood through dota a
connection they wanted to share with the
team of their own this is their story
tal fly Isaac and Yohan notail sunstein
met through video games when they were
14
why grew up in Israel and Canada with
fitness and exercise as a core part of
his identity his father trained him in
martial arts instilling in him a sense
of how important discipline is to any
serious competitor and that became a
core part of his leadership style in
Denmark no tail grew up obsessed with
video games that obsession developed
into a dream and soon he decided to
dedicate himself to them full time while
he was still in high school their paths
first crossed online in Heroes of
Newerth one of several MOBAs that
cropped up between dota and dota 2 the
pair eventually signed with a fnatic
roster that is considered one of the
best in that game's history with wins at
Dreamhack winter 2010 and 2011 and
Dreamhack summer 2011 and 2012 but as
Han began to wind down fanatics roster
transitioned to dota the team didn't
pick up too many wins early on but were
a consistent presence in the top eight
of various tournaments and most notably
picked up a win over no tide hunters
soon to be legendary roster at Thor open
2012
low growl does get that it in reverse
polarity coming on a hottie he's gonna
skewer a back in there and a crit it
instantly killed three heroes from no
tidehunter loaded eyes before he gets to
do anything three thousand damage and
admiralbulldog dies as well and no tie
doctor calls the good game despite
coming short of placing first at a
significant tournament the team was
invited to the International 2013 and
played well in the group stage this
could be the last fight if it goes
poorly for na'vi could cost them the
game sonic blown up instantly by the
carapace of no tail now have those
that's too to fall
they want more Trixie on the back side
they're chomping away they're slapping
them down and Navi got two owed by
fnatic Oh two in Group A one of your
favorites team wipe an exclamation point
on an outstanding performance damn 35 to
13 na'vi just got rolled although their
early tournament performance was
respectable the bracket phase of the
competition proved to be too great a
hurdle for fnatic to overcome triple all
Trump and he will take the top right and
GG comes out fnatic have been a limited
by the Malaysians orange will advance
themselves for the next season didn't
treat fnatic much better the team
performed well at qualifiers and minor
events but the bigger better teams
always want out at premiers but through
their formative years with fnatic fly
and no tails signature styles became
apparent no tail was the team's leader
he was brash loud and animated fnatic or
as I've now been informed Big Daddy
yep
why not fly on the other hand became a
student of the game he was the man
behind fanatics drafts and served as a
calming presence for the team even
inside if I think that was probably
loose I would still say mentality
outside of dota 2 they were the best of
friends but that chemistry alone was not
enough to carry fnatic to victory
against the game's best teams BKB black
hole he wants to turn around them
parties he actually finds notes on the
back side he gets a double kill for each
down flight as well I believe they used
the feed script there to secure those
and looking for more in the end but
bring down 3 and GG
fnatic on 14 fnatic and that's that's
tough they had a lead in Game one it
wasn't a massively Bill's definitely a
game which they felt they should've won
fnatic would make it back to TI in 2014
but this time they bombed out in the
group stage Bogner is still back yes he
got him he actually makes another nugget
sorry boys fly back to China as well as
Nagas are and the rapier is in the hands
of nature's prophet the damage is too
much no fortification for fnatic his
armor again flying no tail were the
first to leave fnatic following their
abrupt ti4 exit the duo joined up with
legendary natus Vincere players puppey
and kuroky and alliances s4 to form team
secret
according to no tale the organisation
was supposed to be something different
most dota teams would switch rosters
just days after a tournament if they
didn't win secret was intended to be a
place where the players would work
things out instead and at first it
looked like things are not going though
according to plan well they see back
then at the purge Goes Down and there
could be
GG is the call from the US team they are
time to be punished like this team
secret will quickly claim game number
two but behind the scenes that wasn't
the case
fly was removed from the support role
and pushed to position - he wasn't
leading the team and he wasn't drafting
he was out of his element and unable to
show what had made him so valuable to
fnatic seen this before in other games
as well and actually in dota 2 as well
but where you build a super super team
and inevitably one of the players is
highlighted as the weak link as it were
and he's been highlighted as that
already but it doesn't mean he's a bad
player by December secret kicked fly why
ended up wandering for a bit playing for
me pwned an EU stack and eventually
complexity gaming in na no tail didn't
stick around much longer by January he
was off secret as well and went to cloud
9 it was the first time fly and no tail
ever played on different teams from
January to August 2015
the Brotherhood forged by dota was
broken up neither player made any
significant waves leading up to TI 5 but
the tournament brought them back
together only on opposite sides of the
battlefield complexity stomped c920 in
the group stage but both teams would end
up drowning in the deeper waters of the
lower bracket team after a season of
playing apart with little success
between them flyin no-tail decided
something needed to change major and TI
victories had escaped the duo's grasp
time after time they weren't young
rising stars anymore they were veterans
that had supposedly hit their peak and
they weren't going to get signed as a
package deal but fly and no tail knew
they were better together they were
tired of teams kicking players right
after TI the knee-jerk decision always
seemed to make sense in the moment but
it rarely panned out so they put their
heads together and
an organization that believed in working
through mistakes and focused on
developing a core set of players they
built the foundation of og monkey
business we wanted people to feel
comfortable to be able to share whatever
they have to say and just you know have
some fun together while still working
towards the same goal so it was two
different things flying fly brought moon
meander with him from complexity and the
team went on to recruit crit a longtime
Danish player who had yet to get a big
break on a major team and then there was
miracle a pub star with the highest MMR
in the world with fly and no tales
philosophy of positivity and
perseverance fueling them the new roster
announced themselves to the dota world
it's rapidly gonna be burned out of all
of this pity back in big daddy bro tells
you've been control bring up with a
shallow grave still there icebergs dead
air oh well that's it's everything
27 days ago one kill in exchange for
like seven and Goren is coming back to
look around to be the eighth and GG is
gonna be called before that could happen
so finish off the queen of pain and seal
kit it'll just diner right clicks
miracle uses the ultimate requiem of
souls will connect on to era with
nowhere to go he is just gonna stand his
ground and fall now the oles put up on
the witch doc your hands Ken's gonna get
take it out ends up being a 4-4-2 and
that's it good game is called an IP will
fall
- nil - monkey business after qualifying
for the Frankfurt major monkey business
rebranded as OG and entered their second
ever land tournament with tons of
promise pundits felt that OG were strong
but - green to lift the trophy in terms
of land experience the players
individually on OD has a lot but as a
team they're yet to perform they were at
MLG as their first land together and
they went out pretty early on at first
Oh G proved them right the group stage
was rough and two losses to Vega
squadron forced them down to the lower
bracket now Vega squadron on the victory
March straight through middle lanes will
be your second team in the top bracket
from this group for any other team that
would have been the end of the line the
road to victory was too long and riddled
with a gauntlet of dota twos most
dangerous teams but og was built to
prevail through adversity fly-in no
tails better and experience resulted in
a team that was made to work together
and win and they did on to DJ that's the
jump for Fisher as well it comes true
for the Bulls internal kill straight
foot grip and after can they turn they
get the winces girls up on to miracle
he's gonna be able to live don't fight
or is that they finally go down as a
one-for-one no telling what
Mineski came next and crumbled under oh
geez might he's gonna get silenced shots
come out as well but a service that's a
hero ice blocks to fly across that's a
nice Tony wait they'll get the Night
Stalker but no tell studies go to work
miracle as well with the record is a
snowball to buy them some time but
they've lost the drought they've lost
the AAA they're gonna lose the test
they're going to lose the Venge for Ted
only cuckoo surviving and GG is called
it's all too much from mineski og just
outclassing than this series next was
virtus Pro oh jeez first challenge but
og rallied after a first game loss took
the series 2-1 if they can find the
jumpy like of the vision Musa who the
curse of the turquoise five strikes
wondering what's the BKB whatever they
got this here in the circle I [ __ ]
say that praise be quite gonna get
stoned up they'll lose the dogs here but
they will find the been no response to
fly with the grave though Dre is going
to be kept alive for the nightmare crits
not dead yet
oh gee buddy surviving he won't go down
as well if double killed former cosa 3 4
they get their home triple kill for
miracle after casting aside see Dec
gaming EE home and TI 5 champions Evil
Geniuses OG had finally made it to the
grand finals it's been it with
incredible story and the first team ever
to come from the very first round best
of 1 games and reach a grand final at a
valve sponsored event there they face
team secret the team that kicked fly in
no tail all those months ago the team
that led them to play a part
the team that Oh G was built to be
better than by Santos Mars gonna break
and we hop well fetch across her misery
massive was it down to the start much
like the puppy dropping down low this
two-year islam
misery started low implies the culinary
talents bomb kills her energy it can
find this lives but that it's going to
be in fact they just call it the father
timing is up Chi Chi energy will take
game the bull one with a bundle of
gleameil up there's no way he can find
pilot I say sitting in the trees for as
long as possible supposed to write with
miracle getting the Thunder for a misery
he'll go down as well away
secret they've committed too much and
they might be in this fight he's
observing in a port so you hit the bike
amplify light either they need his
control in this engagement but achieve
the kind of already one that burns the
queen of pain a puppy with his lip gloss
I see what the concoctions well he can't
do enough he'll end up dying highlight
diet here's you die back go here or is
down from team secret want to go with a
shadow played him to come underneath the
observer in century was they can see him
clearly we could feel trigger against
the BKB open for Zod attacking it
o'clock might get the fact that the
hookshot weren't getting outta here the
miracle detaching me two minutes on the
sidelines buyback is available for pilot
eyes of the runs of the larder secret
would momentarily halt
oh geez momentum in Game three and with
that roll forward crib Lisa crying bleak
himself off the misery equal to the toss
and that as a team white but in Game
four the Green Machine would not be
denied eighteen seconds without spin
miracle is feeding into that melee rax
and how he actually still spin as well
he can take a little bit the time in
chopping appoint three-man rush and be
looking for the damaged ball the
concoction is gonna be there how much do
they got miseries boss optimal way
your requiem for a miracle where the
rain is combined some secrets to take
and turn by 7:30 I've got it that's
called the TTL from secret
way through the lower bracket and will
be clean the champion
[Applause]
dinah turn made to live here in
Frankfurt that victory fly-in no tail
lifted their first valve trophy to cap
off the most incredible lower bracket
run in dota twos storied history make
huge run the dream runner
achieving what no other team is dunham
and no other team will probably achieve
for a very long time secret would avenge
themselves at the shanghai major a few
months later
knocking OG into the lower bracket which
this time oh gee could not recover them
but despite their laps and form OG stuck
together and kept pushing all the way to
the manila major which they would
conquer from the upper bracket OG doing
in lakewood they can't withstand the
punishment oh gee for the manila major
champions things were looking good for
OG in 2016 but at TI
the team that had looked so good all
year bombed out after back-to-back
losses to MVP phoenix and colossal
underdogs TNC the mid do they go for a
gg push yeah they are they're attacking
the t4 towers are Ray the jump ball up
the crib he needs help enough that wall
will be enough
[Applause]
Oh illuminated on day number two of ti6
oh geez early TI exit was a tough pill
to swallow for no tail and fly okay I
got a team at myself I wasn't able to
get in true with everyone this
tournament brings up something like
tournaments don't either
like forget strategy or the strategy the
apart and it doesn't matter you know we
could be like a super like way better
than other team but they have that fire
and we don't we're gonna lose this time
change was unavoidable crit miracle and
moon me and her left and were replaced
by GX s4 and honor but fly-in no tail
the spirit of og was still there and
they had no plans of giving up with
their new lineup og bounced back from
the disappointment of Ti at the Boston
major holy dropping two games enroute to
capturing an impressive third valve
major title you guys read in your entire
team and you did it again you two are
the only survivors and that's your third
major how I was as possible how you've
done it
I mean definitely thanks to these three
oh no way and of course coach said but I
mean we just just play like some oldies
you know we just made some rusty dota
and then we get carried in spring of
2017 oh gee attended the Kiev major
making it all the way to the grand
finals
they've never lost a major finally then
they've had three out of three so far in
their fourth final as an organization I
wonder whether that will stay on as well
their opponent virtus Pro came into the
series of hot it only dropped two games
the entire tournament and were being
hailed for their incredible flexibility
and ferocious team fighting Jamie start
to outplay VP down the stretch here and
now they've got them on the run they
damaged the ones they chased forward
their absolute destruction
BGK made but door slams shut and cuts
them off at that VP right now absolutely
incredible
as the only CIS team in the bracket
stage VP had the crowd at their backs
and now face to face with the defending
champions they looked poised to drag Oh
G into a bloodbath will they be the ones
to stop oh ji-ho G took Game one quit yo
cept they need to get him out of here
the agency one was still up in the
octane gauge beautifully proposed him
pulling back in no one this time energy
will the damage be enough but winner
tough to lose the light back in again
tegus he wanted will trigger Masha
he's checking out the moment he will
talk but another control control spun up
into the solar he's trying out
everyone's gone to him but VP answered
back by taking two games in a row to
bring him back in the observe the
centuries the alpide it catches out of
this to be big the word pokemon however
on the back lines rock may turn this
fight around banana get the digits he
won't kill long solo is there's no one
he's the one doing the murdering at the
bad claws
turn down for the moment the normal
treatment all the sons of mr. golden
inside
faith is the king of ludicrous dammit he
is Randy triple killer Gigi
they're coming in the stunt it's already
there they've got Anna s for your septa
will send up the dragon I set him up for
the fewer fact omen upon this fight
maybe with the stern gate they're
keeping no one out of the engagement
allowing Anna Rinder tell to Fergus on
the immortal I don't know why they want
to do that Randy's still alive down a
one-third life the rock will drop is the
extra stuff that bouncing around double
buybacks Rick no chances onto the ball
as I come back in the three men are paid
the damage it needs to happen right now
banner was just standing his ground and
no the Lord
this should be in this should be TG
because you're good energy one foot in
the grave and then he pushed in by the
Russians but his purse Sam winder Jane
for the face of the
gave up in the kiev a took grand final
following game 3 morale was low but
after years in the trenches together no
tail and fly were too worried thing
about it this way this is what I'm doing
I'm gonna have another thousand dollar
games I might as well enjoy them each
one of them no reason to be sad or mad
about any of them be happy that we're
here we have this chance it's not over
nothing's over how many best of threes
did we do this yes that's two more game
to think about and that positive
never-say-die attitude was rewarded in
game four they've already got one city
one shoulder now okay that might be one
way to do it on 2g ranks but mpus bear
jumping forward with a double silenced
juggernaut as well as crystal mates
nothing they can do a pond from bud
Ramsey's the TV on the rock it actually
connects to throw away the TV on this
one quick on these lashes doesn't get
the lucky pounds and so G Rex will be
able to escape this all the will come up
I'm trying to why she stopped this but
then again you got monkey keep getting
all the way through Randy's will try and
be involved as well sneakers you're off
he saw the one to add up the flame got
protection he's her jumps born actually
into a kill was it taking solar the
spirit away the school will work but the
defense's bird allows him to escape the
cake and catches turns his fall they can
dirt the ball who he actually put down
the hall of not required the kill the
rolling away over G jumping : they are
wrong they connect some pasta he work at
the appeal this can be no RPG team
played the copper the black ball
Virginia will do what has to be done in
four years of dirt-eater Val tournaments
naval force and gave 5 BP stormed out of
the game
taking a commanding lead in Game five
before this time is power of the dazzle
tape a change forward looking for the
damage with a chakra they push him
around in dirty tail - a john-boy the
host of bacon eggs on the RD they're
gonna kill him up this is a big fight if
they can keep it contesting that the
rock will bust your crazy mother it's
huge
but no one is just doing his work he's a
path through this he wants one more hit
on her tail solo Ashley gets the kill
because of the fatal want the enigma
agents
down for our G the cella tranquil keep
my life
G risk up a little bit of space remember
he's the one carry the jet possible told
him up bring him down 30 hours
volleyball 13 been falling apart but
through sheer will and determination
Oh G clawed their way back from the
brink of annihilation but he wants a
punch into Randy's Dearing's doesn't
actually get in the passion we ever
concocted preparing the rock with the
fatal bones will connect down you'll
step to the keeping early out of the
fight and the big word they're holding
him there with the damage you'll drop
the hammer for the batch again is still
doing his work there tell this timbersaw
feed the man doing the damage until Anna
vamos a lockdown you actually have the
fight going the way of our G from there
Oh G couldn't be stopped trying to gun
the wall to every can now the door it's
our banana meeting it is B gave me up
the whole stop was the 17th the time is
there's no one and getting a very
ineffective open from him you brought
down the tree but a 1 cos potato will
fall Anna need to do more damage no one
sorry the double kill all this ground
ready is bad he cannot get away
and they don't for cats out low the rock
will drop but I just don't have the
damage to repeller G Jay King will be
claimed for time D'Arnot ur major
winners here at Kiev unfortunately that
win at the Kiev major is oh geez last
premier win although the team struggled
yet again at TI 7 and the roster may
have changed flyin no tales philosophy
remains the same treat people the way
you want to be treated work hard like
enjoy the challenges in life and accept
the failures along the way like they're
there and you can't run away from them
always do your best and remember to
always get back up no matter where you
are in life over the course of eight
years fly in no tail have grown
alongside one another and through the
Solidarity and friendship they found in
each other they assembled one of DotA's
most stable successful and beloved
organizations
whether or not they win TI during their
careers remains to be seen but one thing
that can't be denied is the
determination they've shown along the
way to confront every challenge together
can't stress on it more
honestly if these two guys are not only
just in the game incredible but out of
the game thanks for watching if you want
more great content just like this be
sure to hit the subscribe button